so let can we talk about Tiger King oh
yeah yeah yeah let's get into that can
we just go off on that fur and for big
big spoiler alert he's gay so I don't
know I don't know what if anyone you
know if any uh homophobic people were
going in this series you know he better
not be gay if that was a deterrent for
you I'm sorry
yeah he's gay yeah there was any like
yeah exactly I was just gonna say like
gun-toting dudes who are like I like
this guy and Bearden is my type of type
of dude you know better not be any dudes
he'd better not be into them though he
is he's very gay now man dang it yeah
now he uh
Joe Joe the tiger King what the [ __ ]
where do you even start with that story
it is holy [ __ ] how many episodes you
watch I'll finished it oh yeah okay good
yeah we did two last night it's I
couldn't [ __ ] believe believe the
twit like the turns that show it went oh
man and just too just a Tarantino the
[ __ ] to like go all the way to the end
to [ __ ] that the dude who managed his
campaign weird is gonna speak freely
about the [ __ ] yeah
spoiler alert just fast forward if you
haven't watched it or just pause it go
spend six hours and come right back
it's definitely worth it it's the best
show I've seen in such a long time oh
yeah yeah best like documentary when
that dude was like you know the biggest
irony is that the whole thing became
about people and no one is even talking
about saving these animals I was like I
know oh my god I know
me too I was like holy [ __ ] you're right
yeah also so like weirdly vain yeah what
is it about these people that are
obsessed with these big cats that make
them also just [ __ ] obsessed with
themselves yeah bizarre it's such a you
know it's it's like um you know what
okay sorry my brain is like going off
but you know the first thing that jumped
out at me do you remember
all back there was this guy he was in
like a bunch of youtubers videos and he
had like exotic like reptiles and stuff
do you mean yeah that's he was like the
first thing that came to my mind as I'm
watching this and I thought holy [ __ ] is
he one of these people like yeah and I'm
not trying to throw him under the bus or
anything but it just it made me question
anytime like I've had the opportunity to
see an exotic animal and that guy Jeff
who ran that [ __ ] business in Vegas
I remember that [ __ ] bust do you
remember that bus no dude I remember
that [ __ ] bus I saw that [ __ ] I
remember like you saw ads for it yeah
and I'm my mind just being blown like
holy [ __ ] that's what that was like I
distinctly remember that bus I had no
clue you know what it meant I thought I
was like a [ __ ] like Siegfried and
Roy type ad like there's some show out
of casino with Tigers and [ __ ] bro that
what happened he's a [ __ ] that guy was
holy hell dude that last scene where
they're sitting he's sitting with his
pregnant wife and he's like and he's
like yet where we're gonna induce labor
in like a week and then we're gonna get
her back in the gym yeah I was like holy
[ __ ] dude yeah and then he's like and
we're getting a nanny to look at and he
holds up a picture of her and he's like
so bad she said we could get one if I if
I get to pick her I was like Jesus [ __ ]
you slimy dick yeah yeah you think his
dick actually slimy yeah I bet you he's
got like a real just yeah like super
slimy taste like a worm it's like old
chicken yeah smells sour anyway yeah I'm
sorry I'm not trying to jump all over
with the damn documentary but no I I it
kind of blew my mind how that dude who's
the guy who like built the cult out of
it what was his name
let me forget the cast ratio no that was
the main guy right now those man guy it
was like dawn dawn dawn hangers done I
was like a R or something
cast hold on I gotta I gotta just export
something real quick so keep talking
just no no it's fine it's gonna take me
five seconds dude I think that's the
funniest part about this quarantine is
that I still feel like I'm just busy
like I'm not not working kind of thing
you know yeah I mean it just feels like
feels like it used to feel sort of just
in terms of like just all we had to do
is just sit around and make fake [ __ ]
all the time yeah you know all right so
I'm I'm looking up the guy's name from
he's the guy that like baaah baaah like
baaah he's like I don't doc annal doc
doc yeah I was close I said dawn yeah
sorry sorry no you're right I shot you
down that's my bad did the fact that he
first of all goes why Bhagavan is just
like when when I heard when I heard him
say that [ __ ] I was like get the all the
way the [ __ ] out of here man I there's
nothing more that drives me crazy than
like [ __ ] like Hari Krishna dudes who
like rename themselves but they're like
from [ __ ] Orange County yeah bruh you
are not [ __ ] Swami pre Ananda
whatever the [ __ ] you're David and you
shaved your head but I totally totally
agree and but it was also like that that
like before they revealed that they went
into his like sexual history with all of
his like wives and the fact that he
would like groom these women he would
like recruit them when they were 16 or
17 and then like groom them to [ __ ] him
and then and then they wouldn't be able
to leave because they had no idea what
the [ __ ] else to do
yeah that's left that's a straight-up
abuse yeah that's dark dude there's a
dark [ __ ] [ __ ] so when they said he
called himself like the Lord or whatever
I was like yeah okay that makes perfect
[ __ ] sense these guys another slimy
douchebag dude and it's I mean that's
it's it's wild that first of all I would
have thought that would have been way
more discussion about him it like at
least I mean I guess given the context
he's probably not that important and the
scope of everything we got going on but
that that's like some art Kelly [ __ ] no
I know it's the same [ __ ] thing like
I feel like he has to be yeah there has
to be some
like invested investigation into that or
something I mean what can they do though
those girls are like there now and like
I'm like yeah I don't know man it's
[ __ ] up it's so wild and you can see
the look in his eye that guy is off the
rails oh he was awful
so like high on himself - yeah like
they're all just so weirdly vain and
like hedonistic yeah right yeah and it
was what tripped me out was seeing that
clip at the end of Joe who is the tiger
king he's like the basis of the
documentary seeing him like so loving of
the animals and seeing him say like oh
these animals belong in their natural
habitats which are not in America and
it's like the fact that they show that
after and then you see what he had
become you're just like goddamn what oh
my god dude when he when he at the end
when he drops that line where he's like
about that about the orangutangs or
whatever mm-hmm when he was like I he
was like I we sent them to a zoo in
Florida and they spent you know the
first entire day together hugging each
other because they were in separate
cages for ten years at my zoo and yeah I
I knowingly uh I've helped that deprived
them of that for ten years I knowingly
deprived them of that love that they had
for each other
how that it's heavy as [ __ ] dude mm-hmm
and in [ __ ] man that that that just that
man looking in the mirror moment he had
right there that [ __ ] is just deep deep
regret you know what I mean I yep oh my
god oh and then with like the the
footage of him like in the prison just
like half of his head yeah whatever that
camera was mm-hmm and his bangs are all
brown cuz the blonde is all grown out
and he's just like yeah just depressing
dude and like the weird irony of him
ending up in a cage for the rest of his
life mm-hmm yes man what a great deal so
here's what's crazy damn look at that
irony [ __ ] awesome awesome watch
though I mean it was right no it
completely
their shows make you feel like that no
that's the best doc I've seen in a
minute anyway you were about to say
here's a crazy thing yeah
so we're also hired like I really would
remind me after this I don't want to
forget the lady Carol who they think Oh
her husband yeah but continue so here's
that I ever tell you about the time I
went to I went to this place in like
rural Oregon and it was yeah yeah you're
like animal yeah [ __ ] okay well it was
exactly like that
that's what's throwing me off about the
whole thing I'm watching this and I'm
like I've been to one of these places
and all the people there were exactly
the [ __ ] same as these people it was
a cult it oh they all they all but so
they had like you know these giant we
ended up there because I think I've told
this on the podcast maybe before but
I'll just say yeah is it's relevant but
it was one of my friends relatives lived
on this sanctuary was an exotic animal
sanctuary and so they had like five
lions like ten giant Tigers they had
like pant the Black Panthers they had
Cougars they had everything on this
giant same thing like giant plot of land
all they built it out cages everything
and they had these insane animals that
we woke up and we stayed there because
it was like we were road tripping and so
we had to stay there overnight and my
friends like yeah my friend's relative
lives on this exotic animal sanctuary we
could stay with them when we're passing
through and the have some breakfast say
hi and then we can leave and I was like
okay cool and he's like it's a cult
though and I was like what what do you
what do you mean he's like it's a it's a
cult it's a full-on cult I don't know
what that means I just know it's a cult
we just be prepared to like see some
weird [ __ ] and I was like okay we're not
gonna get like sacrificed or anything
he's like I don't know maybe and I was
like well let's go I want to see some
lions and so we we go there and like you
know they had all the crazy animals that
we woke up in the morning to like lions
roaring it was [ __ ] bizarre
like felt like we were straight up in
South Africa or some like that anyways
we find out that we're basically talking
to them about I don't know how much of
this I should like air out but it's it's
really [ __ ] crazy and interesting so
we're like talking today it's like
everything's normal we're having dinner
with them or whatever and they're
talking with our cat and they're like oh
yeah that cat is is reincarnated and
we're like oh what's up and they were
like yeah we had a we had a cat that I
was really close with he passed away and
basically we brought him back into this
cat's body and now he's that cat he's
the old cat he's not the disc at anymore
man we're like I don't we thought he
were they were joking so we were like oh
ya know for sure
yeah and they were like no no this this
is this is the other cat I know it's him
I can see it I can sense it I know it's
him we brought him back and I was like
oh [ __ ] and that was just that that was
just the start of it the rest of the day
was so [ __ ] weird dude we go to this
to this giant dojo where they like all
worship one of the women that lives
there and she's just a human woman
that's just like them same age and
somehow she's convinced him to like all
worship her I don't know it was crazy it
was [ __ ] crazy and by the it by the
morning we were like are we got a dip
yeah we're like thanks for breakfast bye
that is that's that's honestly that's
[ __ ] that's impressive that you made
it out of that that's one legitimately
like a little bit weird if we're like
what we don't know what these people
what their motive is here actually is
some different [ __ ]
you